une large voie bordée de petits
immeubles récents et de terrain vagues
en cette fin d'après-midi la rue du père
Favron de Saint-Pierre sanime au bout la
modernise de la Ravine Blanche se dresse
comme pour veiller sur le quartier
veillez sur le quartier ou rappeler la
mémoire du père Favron
est-ce que vous savez qui était le
perfavron non malheureusement
handicapés c'est-à-dire soirée muet
et puis surtout à bois d'olive il a
monté une maison pour s'occuper des
handicapés
René Jean-Baptiste faveron est né dans
une modeste famille près de Saint-Malo
en 1911
entrez en 1929 dans la congrégation des
eodistes il est ordonné prêtre dix ans
plus tard la même année il est attaché
au diocèse de la Réunion c'est à Saint
Louis en 1946 que débute son œuvre dans
le garage de la cure il installe le
premier hôpital l'Union catholique de
Saint-Louis est né elle deviendra plus
tard l'Union des œuvres sociales de la
Réunion
il ouvre également une école
d'aide-soignante un village d'une
cinquantaine de maisons à Cambour un
foyer de jeunes travailleurs et le
premier magasin pilote de la Réunion
pour offrir au plus nécessiteux des
produits à moindre coût en 1957 le
centre de rééducation pour jeunes
aveugles et sourds et transférés à
Sainte-Marie il est dirigé par des
religieuses que le père a fait venir un
an plus tôt de Marseille
le père Favron décède en 1968 à Nantes
il repose à bois d'olive